today we're gonna do something a little
different we're gonna play a game of
would you rather so between the two
things and then briefly explaining why
you choose one of the other all the
unrelated stuff so first would you
rather screw up every take yourself or
someone else screw up your best take oh
we choose none of the above
no you've got a Pixies I I I'm gonna go
yeah you go I'd rather someone screwing
my take I just can't handle you know
screwing someone's think that's too much
no no that's horrible especially if it's
our Evan see yeah I think I agree I'd
rather yeah I'd rather be angry at
someone else for myself yeah cuz it's a
lot to bring home to come home and just
like listen every time I couldn't get a
difficult one terrible one that was a
great question all right I'm doing a
little bit of a lighter one then would
you rather work on a set with no food or
no caffeine for me no caffeine because
caffeine makes me so I - sips on I feel
like I'm on drugs actually do anything
no caffeine because no food would you
rather this one's a little complicated
would you rather have to get into the
headspace for a scare scene yourself or
have the director surprise scare you
while filming I would rather get into it
myself
I like the control of you know making
myself feel things and not be interested
not be scared I like to be surprised but
knowing that I'm gonna get surprised no
I don't want surprises like I took the
love I want if there's a set that I need
to go in and see it for the first time I
want to see it for the first time on
camera but I don't want to go in and
then a shark come out and hit me or
something you know
the best of both worlds whether it's
this movie or any other TV show or
another movie you've done has there ever
been you know a scare sequence or an
idea that you couldn't shake off after
that kept you up at night even after
filming was no room for me when we were
filming the pilot of American Horror
Story there's this scene where there's
the this character this demon baby
character it's called the infant tada
and it has these like really gross long
nails and there's a scene where it's
coming at me and I'm just and I have to
scream there's like these strobe lights
going on and Ryan Murphy's in the
background like more flat like more
flashing more scary I'm like and that's
that with me for weeks
one demon babies you know I know about
those hello
would you rather face off against VALIC
Annabelle or Bathsheba come on you know
I'm gonna save Alec because I kind of
have an idea of how to maybe you know
conquer that one
so normally I'll pose this question and
I'll go either demonic or slasher and I
always would rather pick the slasher
because it still feels like you could
run away you can get away at some point
anything anything supernatural here
you're kind of screwed yeah all right I
have a different version for you then
sorry would you rather be buried alive
or have a xenomorph in your stomach
hello I had a little more fun before Oh
reaches before so we're familiar wait
wait other with good luck very aligned
alive or or give birth to a xenomorph uh
chest burster oh okay I've got one it'll
go with your filmography better all
right I'll just I'll just want answer
that don't you do it's like they're both
really bad option there's you know
motors quit you don't you just die until
your heart stops all right all right see
you broke that down reasonably thank you
we settled on the right hand side is it
for me sorry would you rather be put in
a loop of the nun or American Horror
Story Murder House final girl style
I think Murder House final girl style
because I mean come on yeah would you
rather work with an actor who has a
method actor or someone who improvises a
lot right I think my instinct is work
with a method actor cuz I I can give
them space I know how to handle that
I mean he's come right it's not my
preferred choice but I would pick that
as opposed to someone who improvises cuz
I feel like I would I know I figured
like a little bit is fine but otherwise
I'm too off-kilter all the time it's
like a little stability but the better
under John rabe because when we did the
hit with Melissa McCarthy I she
improvises all the time I know that's a
joy she constantly and begins
improvising when there's a nun chasing
us and that we got really heavy
emotional scene yeah exactly that was
not work yeah would you rather have to
fake sneeze or fake vomit in a/c sorry
um I think fake sneezing because fake
vomiting it's like a bunch of chunky
soup and oatmeal Estes give me give me
your best knees very Irene I'm assuming
that's the robe upside
I think you're too much fun you have to
go we've never seen her don't worry